the bottom line is they were more
physical football team
um it could be highlighted in terms of
their front and our inability to
to run the ball but just in general i
thought
in all elements of play they were more
physical groups
buffalo bills are doing what great teams
need to do in december they're playing
well in winning games the pittsburgh
steelers who were 11-0
before december not technically i think
one of those games was in december
thanks to the whole delay
of the of the week 12 game against the
ravens but for the games that were
supposed to be played in december
they're 0-2
shireen that's not what you want to do
as you're trying to get yourself ready
for the postseason
we did a re-watch of that steelers bills
game it was a tough one to pick it was
too close to call
but the bills based upon their recent
performances looked like they would
emerge victorious and eventually
they did even though for a while the
game was in dispute
let's uh focus on some of the aspects of
that game we both went back and watched
it via the excellent nfl
game pass feature shireen after taking a
closer look at the sunday night game
from week 14 who was the best player on
the field
well i i think it was stefan diggs i
mean he had 14 targets 10 catches 130
yards and a touchdown i just thought he
was dominant
and you know he's third in the nfl now
with 1
167 yards he has 100 catches he has five
touchdowns
and mike i think this is one of the rare
times that a trade has worked out for
both teams perfectly and i don't think
either team would change
what's happened when you look at justin
jefferson and what he's done for
minnesota 65 catches
over a thousand yards and seven
touchdowns they've replaced him nicely
but the bills wouldn't give up digs at
this point even to get jefferson and i
just think
it was a great trade for both teams
diggs has played great and
you know when he when he played most
great was the second half he didn't have
a big first half he had three catches
and didn't do a whole lot
second half he had seven catches for 92
yards and a touchdown and i thought he
was a real difference maker in the
second half
against a really good defense i think
the bills would be crazy to not do a
straight up deal for justin jefferson
for digs right now if they could
i mean at the time the deal was done we
didn't know what the first round was
going to bear we didn't know how these
receivers were going to work out that's
part of the risk you take
when you get the lottery ticket and you
begin to scratch it with the edge of the
quarter
right for the vikings it worked but it's
a hell of a risk because for every
justin jefferson they've got a troy
williamson in their history of drafting
first round receivers
laquan treadwell stunned percy harvin
was good for a while randy moss
was great it's worked out so far for
justin jefferson
and i yeah cordell patterson was it was
a mixed bag and and he ended up being
better elsewhere frankly
than he ever was in minnesota but
jefferson has been phenomenal i i
if i was the vikings would definitely
not trade justin jefferson for stefan
diggs straight up and if i was the bills
i would jump on that in a heartbeat but
but for what the bills are currently
trying to do which is supply josh allen
with weapons and they didn't have enough
weapons
this is what you do this is the sure
thing because if they had used their
first round pick on a receiver there's
no guarantee the guy is going to step in
and be good
always go for the sure thing when you're
trying to build something so it is a
win-win
and uh and diggs has been great
and he's helped make josh allen better
and so
look long term the vikings are better
off with justin jefferson they're paying
him
a lot a lot less over the next few years
and they're going to have him a lot
longer
but for what the bills are trying to
build this was the right move
and again yes diggs proved it on sunday
night with 10 catches for 130 yards
and a touchdown uh and it came at a
moment where
it just felt like the bills were
asserting themselves in the game where
it was still kind of up in the air
and they had that drive and it was
capped in the third quarter with a
touchdown by diggs and it's like okay
the bills are winning this game you just
get the you just feel it at that point
the bills are winning this game for me
the best player was josh allen and even
though he wasn't as spectacular as he
was
the prior week that's a bar that you're
not going to match each and every week
he has the mobility he has the arm
strength he has the accuracy
to be one of the best quarterbacks in
the nfl now in the first half
it wasn't great it stepped up in the
second half when they pulled away look
at that 14 for 20
70 completion percentage in the second
half
162 yards 11 rush yards and two
touchdowns and the interception
that was a flukey weird volleyball
bump set spike type of a play that you
know it happens and it goes on the
quarterback statistic when it happens
but it's a fluke
so it's not like he made a horrible
throw it's not like he made a lot of
horrible throws he didn't make many
horrible throws
his completion percentage first half
wasn't great the steelers defense
stepped up the studio's defense was
better i think much better in the first
half in the second half
but but the bills stuck with it and uh
and
credit to them for sticking with it and
not not
you know realizing in the first half hey
this week isn't going to be as easy as
last week
they still found that that ability to
get to the level they needed to get to
to win the game
all right next category from our rewatch
shireen
who was better on further inspection
than it seemed when we watched the game
live on sunday night
well i thought it was tyson olulou and
you know he he's a guy who's kind of
forgotten
in that front because they have all
those name players including tj watt and
cameron hayward and we know all the
names of
of the got to it all those guys make all
the plays but this guy just does all the
dirty work and and he always shows up
every time i watch a
steelers game he's doing something and
he had the only sack of the game that
that was really the most amazing part i
didn't realize they only had one sack in
that game because usually you see the
steelers getting
multiple sacks in every game and they
didn't do it they didn't get to the
quarterback which is part of the reason
they
they lost frankly but he had the only
sack to keep that 70-game streak going
of of a sack
and break the so-called record i know
there's a dispute on really what the
record is but the nfl claims it's a 70
game streak record and so he kept that
going with the one sack that they had
and within those 70 games they've had
237 sacks by 29 different players but
if it wasn't for his sack that streak
would be over at this point and i
thought he played really well in that
game
uh for me it's juju smith schuster who
has kind of become
forgotten and overlooked in pittsburgh
even though he consistently shows up and
performs well
he's had a strange career arc second
season in the league
he has 111 catches 1426 yards he's voted
the team mvp
that decision and the timing of the
announcement was the catalyst for
antonio brown
storming out of pittsburgh never to
return last year they tried to craft him
almost
will him into being a number one
receiver the only problem is
he doesn't have the speed to stretch the
field and i remember seeing the quote in
the offseason last year
that he's working on you know beating
people deep it's not something that you
work on you either have the ability to
beat people
deep or you don't you don't go out and
get faster yeah you can find a way to
get the absolute most out of your
god-given ability when it comes to
running in a straight line and making
cuts and moving
but there are actual limitations on what
you can do he was never going to be a
number one guy
who draws double coverage all the time
last year was disappointing
also because they didn't have ben
roethlisberger for most of the year
this year he's settling into a role
which is possession receiver
guy you can count on tough he had that
that play in the second half where he
just
bowled over one of the bill's defensive
backs he's a guy that ben roethlisberger
needs to be looking to also because
unlike deontay johnson or eric ebron
uh juju smith schuster catches the ball
when you throw it to him so
uh he he's quietly having a great year
he's on pace for 97 catches
and and he's a guy that i think they
just need to keep throwing the ball
to because he's got that mentality he's
got that heinz ward mentality
that the steelers need if they want to
uh to get this thing back on track they
need to rediscover
the toughness that we used to know from
pittsburgh
steelers teams if they're going to
perform in january
like the steelers once did all right
give me someone who had a game
shireen they would like to forget well
you alluded to it mike and i think it's
the obvious choice right deontay johnson
and and maybe you know the very first
play he drops a pass and maybe that game
goes differently if he catches that and
they come back they go three and out
they come back on the second series and
he drops another pass i mean he's wide
open on both of those and no telling how
far he would have gone on either one
and or both of those passes and it
wasn't like they were difficult catches
they were right there for him to catch
and go
he ended up with four catches for 40
yards but he's most remembered for those
two drops that got him a seat on the
bench for the rest of the first half
which is what mike tomlin said he was
going to do if they kept dropping passes
and then we saw eric ebron
drop one later on but he has got to
figure out
how to hold on to the football he is
tops the league
and i know drop passes are kind of a
random stat that who knows if it's
really true but most
places you'll look including nbc sports
have him atop
the drop passes list with nine so we
certainly know he has a bunch it seems
like
it's even more than that but he's got to
figure out a way to hold on the ball
mike if if the steelers are going to do
what they need to do they got to be able
to run the ball
they also have to catch it when ben
roethlisberger puts it right in their
arms
well especially with the high-tech
gloves that they have and i remember
there was a story a few years ago when
rich mckay the chair of the competition
committee was suggesting they were going
to take a look at making those gloves
a little less effective like now that's
not quite the idea you
want guys to be able to make the
one-handed catch we don't want to make
the gloves
less effective it makes the game more
exciting but when guys are dropping the
football the fact that they have these
awesome gloves
where you just stick your hand out and
it's like
velcro and anything that comes across it
is going
to stick to it and you drop those that
really shows a lack
of concentration so i agree with you
deontay johnson has to
step it up it gets in your head he's
trying to run with the ball before he
secures it there are plenty of receivers
who can do that though that's not an
excuse
we see it all the time guys make the
catch
while they're moving with the football
they don't break stride they don't stop
everything they're doing to make the
catch
so uh he just has to work at it and work
at it and work at it and work at it but
then not let it get into his head
for me the guy who had a game that he
should want to forget
is randy fichner the offensive
coordinator and the fact that we really
don't know how to properly pronounce his
name shows he doesn't get enough
scrutiny
right if if he was getting the scrutiny
he deserves we would all know exactly is
it feakner is it feikner is it fichtner
i think it's fichner but i don't know
because he doesn't get scrutinized the
way that he should it's amazing to me
that this guy preserves anonymity when
he's in charge of the offense
for a defensive minded coach and the
offense has completely
lost its way they don't have a
commitment to the running game
they aren't throwing the ball down the
field
the way they should so many of these
passes are short and as chris sims says
they are predictable in their
predictableness that is his phrase not
mine
and it's on the offensive coordinator to
get it under control and if this
is some sort of a weird power struggle
where ben roethlisberger is asserting
himself and being passive aggressive and
changing plays at the line of scrimmage
it's on the coordinator to have the kind
of relationship
with the quarterback to get the
quarterback to do
what the coaching staff wants him to do
one of the risks you take when you pay
one player a ton of money
you give him a ton of power and if he
decides he wants to
basically launch a mutiny in a quiet
sort of way
he can and there ain't a damn thing the
team can do about it
and it's incumbent on the offensive
coordinator to get it under control
rediscover the run and find a way
to get the passing game to work and it's
all on him it's ultimately on mike
tomlin
but within the organization it's on
randy fichner and
with each one of these performances
where we say where's the running game
why are guys dropping passes why aren't
they more effective it all goes back to
him or at least it should shireen
absolutely mike and he's got to do a
better job and ben roethlisberger
frankly's got to do a better job and i
saw some rumblings out there that
is ben's knee hurt you remember back at
the dallas game he took those hit hits
on the knee and left for the locker room
early and all of that
hey he's not on the injury report if
you're not on the injury report
everybody's banged up at this time of
year you got to go play
and you got to make the plays and and
the steelers haven't done that the last
two weeks on offense
they scored two touchdowns on sunday
night and one of those was set up on a
short field with the turnover
well and and the moment that the game
turned and it felt like the bills were
going to find their way out of this mess
was
the play that you picked for further
scrutiny although we don't have time to
really break it down it was simple
roethlisberger threw a ball he shouldn't
have it was intercepted it was returned
for a touchdown
the guy was shot out of a cannon and
that was the moment where it's like okay
the steelers aren't going to find a way
to take this one from buffalo buffalo is
going to assert themselves and win the
game
yeah they were up 7-3 at that point and
then they go down they missed the extra
point so they're up 9-7 at the half that
was a huge turning point and thomas said
it was
the significant play of the game and it
was it was the absolute difference maker
you don't make that play stare down the
receiver throw the interception
if they don't do that maybe they win it
who knows maybe the second half goes
differently but
ben roethlisberger stared the receiver
down they made the pick and and it went
buffalo's way and
and it's you know so many times mike it
comes down to one play and that was the
one play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports